voici notre invité de la semaine
jean luc godard jean luc godard j'espère
qu'il y aura des questions dans la salle
ce sujet de votre film car c'est tout de
même un film qui a passionné à la fois
pour et contre vous savez peut-être
qu'une partie du mois n'ont que
l'unanimité de la tribune a été pour
vous le jour où nous avons parlé du film
à sa sortie mais qu' il y a une petite
unanimité aussi des producteurs
d'émissions c'est à françois régis
duvignau et mois plus tôt contre le film
bernard dort temps à parler
ensuite il ya quinze jours ce qui vous
prouve que le film nous tracasse nous
revenons dessus et il lui est un peu
aussi de notre côté
et puis le mieux dans ces cas là c'est
de demander au metteur en scène de venir
et puis d'en parler avec lui de nous
demander de nous éclairer quand il faut
que tu dises carette a oublié de dire le
titre du film quelques analphabètes qui
l'ont pas vu quand même bon alors
rappelons que jolie pour l'auditeur qui
est loin qui vont alors murray encore
une fille tu as raison et mais
commençons par le commencement
disons à ceux qui peut-être n'ont jamais
vu de film jean luc godard qu'il a
commencé une carrière éclatante avec à
bout de souffle qui a lancé jean paul
belmondo et jean seberg et ensuite il
nous a donné une femme est une femme
avec anna karina le petit soldat que
nous n'avons pas vu ce que certains
privilégiés ont vu mais qui a été
interdit par la censure et non pas pour
des raisons érotique mais pour des
raisons politiques car c'est un film qui
traitait de la guerre d'algérie et
ensuite il nous a donné vivre sa vie le
film dont nous allons parler plus
particulièrement aujourd'hui toujours
avec un à karina et signalons aussi au
passage pour être complet un sketch dans
les sept péchés capitaux ce sketch
c'était la paresse et c'est et eddie
constantine qui le jouet c'était je
trouve un des meilleurs sketchs ailleurs
de ce film bon je n'ai rien oublié jean
luc godard non
bien on pourrait peut-être puisque nous
sommes dans l'histoire dire tout de
suite que vous êtes en train de préparer
deux films je crois un sketch encore une
fois et dites-le nous tout de suite je
tourne à partir de la semaine prochaine
un sketch d'un film italien sketches
dont les trois autres sketchs sont faits
l'un par pasolini l'autre par roberto
rossellini et le troisième par un jeune
metteur en scène qui s'appelle hugues
obry goretti qui a fait un film qui est
passé à cannes cette année que je trouve
excellent qui s'appelle les nouveaux
enjeux qui doit prochainement sortir à
paris ensuite je dois tourner une une
pièce de théâtre d'un écrivain italien
benyamine ohio paulo qui avait été jouée
il ya une dizaine d'années à paris par
michel doré qui s'appelle les
carabiniers et qui était
considérablement remanié par par
rossellini par jean gruault le
scénariste jules et jim et par moi même
un bon qu'est-ce que c'est ce ce qu est
ce que vous allez faire c'est un sketch
moi qui est admis de de science fiction
je ne sais pas encore ce que fait pas
complètement écrit là avant restés
fidèles quand même à vous à vos
principes mais vous pensez que vous
apporterez comme ça où comédiens chaque
jour ce qu'ils ont à tourner une seront
pas ce qui se passe le lendemain et vous
même ou en général c'est ce que je fais
j'explique de leur taille leur expliquer
ce que ce que je veux faire les idées
générales de la chose que qui sont en
général assez précise mais alors risque
par exemple
alors prenons vivre sa vie bernard donc
nous a dit lui même que vous ne savez
pas en fin de compte très bien quel
était le point de départ est ce que vous
avez voulu faire un documentaire sur
prostitution ce que vous avez voulu
montrer une petite demoiselle qui se
prend pour jeanne d'arc est ce que vous
avez voulu nous montrer une personne qui
se posent des problèmes sur le langage
je crois que bernard dort que on ne sait
pas en sortant des films vous ne vous
même ne savait pas c'est un film qui
m'étonne
un peu moins parce que c'est le film que
je trouve de ma part le plus construit
et le plus penser et c'est vraiment
celui que j'ai le plus improvisées
travailler vraiment à la dernière minute
alors je sais pas je trouve je sais pas
comment ça je suis parti d'une idée
c'était au départ truffaut avait une
idée de scénario que j'aimais beaucoup
mais qui est une idée de comédie surtout
c'est l'histoire d'une femme qui qui
chaque mercredi ou chad vendredi pour
augmenter le budget des ménages enfin
vers le trottoir et je lui avais demandé
la permission de comme je le veux faire
un film pour un producteur et je ne
savais pas quoi faire je vais demander
la permission d'utiliser ce point de
départ et je suis pas enfin c'est une
bonne situation il faut enfin je suis
pas arrivé en sortirait finalement je me
suis intéressé je me suis dit je vais
décrire un personnage mon phare puis
petit à petit j'ai des idées mais au
départ ce qui m'a je me suis je me suis
dit je vais me lancer là dedans
une fois qu'on se lance dans les choses
et bien si les choses qu'on fait sont
importantes
on va bien trouver une direction face où
vient la seule idée que j'avais au
départ c'est une idée bien précise le
premier plan qu'on verra on la verra
dodo pourquoi voilà je n'en sais rien
enfin c'est comme ça vous ne venez pas
de clé à nous donner à c'est à dire une
fois ensuite je peux trouver beaucoup
d'explications il est justifié par
exemple une explication
l'explication c'est que c'est une scène
difficile c'est un film que je trouvais
difficile il fallait arriver à
intéresser les gens avec une série de
scènes où ne se passait pas grand chose
donc on peut penser qu enfin au départ
si on voit les gens pendant cinq minutes
de dos on a envie de les voir de face
mais c'est déjà ça de gagné mais oui
mais oui moi j'ai eu peur mais on pense
à des choses comme ça moi je vous
propose exemple si j'ai choisi le film
le court métrage l'amour existe qui est
d'un garçon qui s'appelle maurice pialat
et que le grand prix du court métrage à
venise l'année dernière non seulement
parce que je l'aimais je l'aimais bien
mais j'ai pensé qu'il pouvait servir mon
film dans la mesure où dans son film il
n'y a pas de personnage il ya uniquement
des maisons est comme ça alors j'ai
pensé qu'après vingt minutes de 10
meubles et d'objets les gens seraient
contents de voir des personnages qui
parle dans mon film mais est-ce que
c'est pas un peu paradoxal tout ça il
n'y a pas une part de provocation si
vous mangez vous dire franchement ce que
j'ai dit à ses tribunes j'ai dit si nous
monde pendant 5 minutes au départ les
gens de dos c'est pour nous dire qu'il
se fiche du public et qu'on a pas besoin
de le regarder mais pas du tout non pas
du tout quand vous voyez au t1 des
acteurs qui tournent le dos au milieu
d'une scène vous vous posez pas de
problème au théâtre va le dire est ce
pas non mais non mais c'est parce que
salle c'était c'est parce que ça ne
s'était jamais fait oui mais non
seulement ils nous tourne le dos mon
père la moitié de ce qu'ils disent
on perd pas la moitié qui disent et
adyal je trouve enfin moi je suis
j'essaye de réagir dans mes films compte
le son qui est si vous voulez trop bien
trop bien fait qui est un son
complètement irréaliste par moments des
scénarios il est comme ça mais on nous
dit qu'on fait des films abstrait et
c'est pas vrai on essaye de faire des
films concrets les gens qui font du film
abstrait c'est verneuil c'est delannoy
enfin qui regardaient leurs films enfin
céder c'est un monde qui n'existe pas
oui tandis que nous enfin peut-être
notre monde n'est pas mais nous essayons
d'arriver à serra et le sont partis en
particulier je crois est un problème
important
moi j'aime bien le son du début du
parlant parce que pour la première fois
des gens avaient des arrivées
enregistrées du dialogue avec des micros
et alors il ya une certaine spontanéité
dans la prise de son sens le plaisir
d'enregistrer des gens qui parlent et
c'est un peu ça que j'essaye de
retrouver cette fraîcheur d'autrefois
dans une femme est une femme j'avais
fait exprès de mettre la musique aussi
fort très souvent que les dialogues
or personne ne se plaint à l'opéra de ne
pas comprendre le texte qu'on se dit
oui d'accord mais ce que vous dites là
on vous approuvez on vous désapprouvent
à moitié
le publiant mais je rangeais moi non
mais je crois ça vient uniquement de ce
qu' il faut bien prévenir quand on fait
des choses comme ça l'erreur d'une femme
est une femme savait était enfin c'est
de la part du distributeur surtout de
faire passer ce film pour ce qu'il
n'était pas l'aurait fallu
c'est à dire les gens s'attendaient à
une comédie de boulevard dans un certain
genre et ça n'était pas ça et en france
et ce alors je lui de sciemment contre
ça avec avec beaucoup de mes amis je
suis pour le mélange des genres or on
n'admet pas le mélange des genres en
france tout à l'heure enfin j'entendais
les critiques qui parlait de barratier
je veux dire je ne parle pas du je ne
parle pas du film mais je sais une
critique que je ne ferais que je ne
ferai jamais et il n'y a pas de raison
que dans un film loufoque qu'on ne
puisse pas introduire une séquence
complètement réaliste et gna oui ça il
n'y a pas de ça je crois que tout de
même maintenant beaucoup de critiques
seraient d'accord avec vous mais moi
mais le préjugé des genres est très
forte et mélange des genres à signer en
france
d'accord le mélange il ya la tragédie il
y à la comédie il ya le boulevard ya la
comédie française il ya le théâtre le
théâtre demeure sa comédie de moeurs
le film policier le west end comme ça et
si on fait un film policier on n'a pas
le droit de mettre des gags dedans alors
que les américains en font uniquement ça
enfin il n'y a pas d'accord pourquoi oui
d'accord shakespeare est quand même
votre compte ancêtres pour le mélange
des genres ah oui oui mais en france on
n'influence qu'on est forcé de le dire
mais quand on le dit on livre les
prétentieux une autre question comment
expliquez vous quel est le sens de la
lettre dans ce film pendant une séquence
entière on voit un à karine enfin
l'héroïne du film en train d'écrire
péniblement une lettre pour demander du
travail
pour moi ça me paraît terriblement long
d'abord j'ai fait des concerts la lettre
était beaucoup plus long quand je les
filme et j'ai raccourci j'ai fait des
concessions quand même
et puis ça a toujours été ça c'est un
aspect des choses dans des films enfin
que dont je suis sur un metteur en scène
à hollywood ne pourrait pas faire ça ou
des choses comme ça me laisse faire ce
que je veux dans une certaine mesure et
j'ai toujours il avait toujours eu envie
de filmer quelqu'un qui écrit une lettre
du début à la fin je les fais tu voyais
dans là on retrouve la qualité qu'on
accorde de toute la critique accorda
jean luc godard c'était là jean luc
godard c'est sa spontanéité c'est à dire
de faire ce qu'il a envie de faire
il faut reconnaître que c'est bien rare
au cinéma il passé on comparer par
exemple avec la peinture ou fond vous
aimez moi rire et hommes femmes par
exemple mathieu c'était une action
painting c'est à dire en en quelques
minutes faire un tableau sans savoir du
tout ce que ce sera non non non pas du
tout moi moi je moi je voudrais moi ce
que j'essaie de faire du cinéaste comme
un peintre mais en ce sens que je suis a
sûrement un des seuls même presque dans
le monde à me permettre de faire des
films en arrêtant soudain pendant trois
jours parce que je manque d'idées et en
bas il n'y a pas de raison un peintre un
peintre qui met une touche de coûts qui
met une touche de couleur sur sa toile
qui recule qui regarde à ce moment là en
8 es un ami lui téléphone pour aller
boire un verre or le cinéaste
il n'a pas le droit de faire ça il faut
commencer dès 8 heures du matin 9 heures
du soir et tournez tournez tournez
tournez sans arrêt si on se trompe ça
fait rien il faut tourner oui on je veux
dire moi je réclame le droit contraire
mais non mais ce que vous fassiez de la
recherche est que nous soyons réaction
contre beaucoup de choses je ne
comprends mais il n'arrive pas à cerner
quel est votre univers doux cela car en
fin de compte vous vous laissez aller à
une espèce de spontanéité au fond je me
demande si en ayant tourné le sketch de
la paresse vous ne vous êtes pas un peu
d pas vous même s'il n'est pas un petit
peu
ah oui mais à a certainement mais je
suis très je suis très paresseux et je
me flatte enfin oui non mais moi j'aime
les paresseux des amis mais écoutez je
crois que maintenant vous j'aimerais
savoir un peu les réactions de la salle
s'il ya quelques questions à jean luc
godard car je m'aperçois qu'on pourrait
parler longuement avec lui une question
ici et je voudrais savoir si on verra le
petit soldat
ah oui est ce que la censure va lever
son interdiction est temps que la guerre
d'algérie est terminée ben il ya une
autorisation méchant allusion politique
et en supprimant les scènes de torture
c'est à dire que pour l'instant le film
ne sort pas alors vous vous refusez
faire des coupures
oui absolument oui mais je crois
pourtant ce film il y à une réflexion on
avait envie de vous applaudir parce que
vous aviez vous refusiez des coupures
mais je crois que certains dont d'autres
vous en fait un reproche à propos de ce
film c'est que ce film en fin de compte
parle d'un prêt d'un sujet politique en
guerre d'algérie mais qu'en fin de
compte il ne prend absolument pas partie
et qu'au fond il traite la politique
comme un sujet comme un autre un peu
comme barratier fait la poupée après
louis non c'est un film qui n'est qu'ils
ne parlent pas tellement la galerie il
est situé dans le contexte de la guerre
d'algérie et c'est tout un film qui
rêvent d'une d'une grande confusion
enfin un peu voulu un peu involontaire
et c'est pour ça que les gens ne savent
pas très bien quand ils le voient ils
étaient interdits comme comme film pro
fln et finalement maintenant est
interdite comme film propres os
je crois que j'ai encore une dernière
question une dernière question on en met
la toute dernière vous servir
maintenant vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure du problème que vous avez avec
le son j'ai appris récemment que
françois reichenbach avait résolu ce
problème avec une caméra portative et
qui enregistre en même temps le son est
donc en même temps les bruits ambiants
est ce que ce serait pas donc une
solution puisque sa enregistrant même
temps les bruits en blanc ça fait très
très vite
c'est ce que je vais faire enfin et puis
ça me forcerait à dire du mal de
reichenbach avait qu'un pas merci serge
godard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]